et par une délimitation centrale la
mesure est en place et pourtant la
polémique que ne s'éteint pas il ya
toujours des reproches qui sont faits à
cette nouvelle règle notamment celle
d'être d'avoir été imposé par un
gouvernement parisien ne comprenant rien
aux préoccupations de la france rurale
ça plaît pas du tout cette critique à
christophe castaner qui est entre autres
le patron de la république en marche le
parti présidentiel
il l'a redit ce matin sur france info
moi je suis choqué plus tôt par la
récupération politique que certains font
de ce sujet la récupération politique
c'est celle d'avoir tenté par ailleurs
expliqué que c'était un coup des
parisiens contre les ruraux parce que
les 1 euro euro lé les ruraux il meurt
deux fois plus sur nos routes que les
parisiens le les urbains et donc ce sont
eux les principales victimes dans cette
mesure elle va sauver beaucoup plus de
ruraux que durban
donc je pense qu'il faut arrêter
d'opposer les uns aux autres alors on
continue avec le dossier des critiques
puis après évidemment on donnera la
parole à nos invités et à vous aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux sur twitter hashtags
point de vue hashtag figaro live l'autre
une autre critique et que cette mesure
est mise en place avant tout pour
remplir les caisses de l'état grâce aux
amendes pour ceux qui continueraient à
rouler trop vite
mais là aussi le gouvernement a la
réponse écoutez le premier ministre
edouard philippe
il était ce matin sur rtl ça n'est
absolument pas pour remplir les caisses
puisque le produit des amendes ce sera
systématiquement et exclusivement
affectés aux établissements qui
accompagne le soins et la rééducation de
tous ceux qui ont subi des accidents de
la route
sophie par cette polémique qui ne
s'éteint pas ça vous surprend avec votre
regard de deux journalistes anglo-saxons
non parce que l'étudiant des polémiques
c'est ça va ça ne me reverras certains
ce qui me fera et m'a frappé ces
derniers mois avant à la mise en place
de cette de cette réforme c'est que ce
sujet était déjà sur la table et énerver
beaucoup de monde dans le sur le terrain
depuis le début de l'année donc c'est un
vrai sujet c'est pas quelque chose créer
je pense aux
c'est une polémique oui c'est plus comme
polémique c'est un vrai sujet dans sur
le terrain donc je pense que c'est vrai
que c'est le monde rural qui va être
plus plus touchés par cette cette limite
de vitesse mais l'idée que c'est juste
un peu le me crée pour des femmes
politiques me semble un peu simpliste et
si c'est vrai qu'il ya 300 à 400
personnes a sauvé par an à cause de
cette limite de vitesse
c'est raisonnable c'est pas il me semble
absurde l'idée que cette mesure pour
essayer de remplir les caisses l'état ça
s'est jamais se fier à résoudre le
problème des finances à titre personnel
vous êtes plutôt pour plutôt contre ou
bien ou bien suffit de réserver toutes
les deux peaux très bien et vous bertron
du marais et couteau pour plutôt contre
moi je suis plutôt contre je vous le dis
pour mettre à l'aise les adapté ici je
l' ai même écrit dans un éditorial
mais c'est pas mal intéressant
aujourd'hui moi je suis plutôt pour et
je trouve que c'est intéressant parce
que ça montre la la comme on dit la
polarisation du débat sur tout ce qui
touche l'évaluation des politiques
publiques
parce que il ya eu des chiffres qui ont
été échangés mais peut-être pas assez
il ya une dimension comment dire de
politique un petit peu
que l'on présente et que l'on considère
dans les médias dans l'opinion comme
imposé d'en haut
alors quand ray lui il n'y a pas que
dans les médias parce que le ministre de
l'intérieur si vous lui demandez votre
avis quand les micros sont coupées il
n'est pas enchanté non plus oui mais sur
le fond c'est pas d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est pas une mesure qui est
très coûteuse ces quelques dizaines
peut-être entre 5 et 13 millions d'euros
d'après ce qu'en dit elle a semble-t-il
des effets des effets non négligeables
sur la réduction des mots moi je trouve
que ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle
montre en réalité peut-être la
polarisation de l'économie française
parce que cette limitation comme vous le
disiez elle touche en réalité peu de
gens mais des gens qui circulent
beaucoup c'était à les gens qui sont
dans les territoires ruraux
alors que finalement elle ne coûtera pas
beaucoup à l'économie française parce
qu'elle ne touchera pas le gros des
échanges qui se font en fait au sein des
villes où entre les grandes villes
moi je trouve que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir de façon très concrète
cette polarisation d'économie et de la
vie sociale française autour des grands
centres et je trouve que ça ne pose la
question d'une espèce de planification
peut-être de la décentralisation qui
manque cruellement depuis peut-être une
vingtaine ou une trentaine d'années
frédéric cinq là ça vous paraît une
polémique un peu secondaire ou un vrai
sujet de société cette affaire des 80 km
heure bon le sujet société n'ont
clairement pas jeu
je suis un peu l'impression de tomber de
la lune en fait quand je vois l'ampleur
des débats sur un problème comme ça j -
avant que ça s'occuper en fait 10 km de
moins de plus agir n'a pas roulé
beaucoup pendant les jeux
si vous saviez pour être très honnête
très franc oui je me fous de ce truc là
mais complètement au moins c'est clair
mais sur le terrain c'est un vrai sujet
c'est instantané mans évoquée dans les
conversations bien avant dans la
polémique je pense que les gens sont en
parlent et qu'ils ont en fait marc
singer loquace et ils s'en foutent aussi
mais ça sera pas présent manifestement
pas tout le monde en parle autant que je
comprends mais je suis sûr que votre
point de vue est intéressant et oui mais
honnêtement 10 km h de plus dit que je
ne comprends pas ceux qui qui qui
section qui ont les cheveux hirsutes en
disant mais c'est inacceptable de
nourriture et vitesse de 10 km h coup
typiquement je comprends pas votre point
de vue si vous disiez tout à l'heure que
vous étiez opposé et je comprends pas
ceux qui se félicitent de cette
réduction de 10 km heure en disant vous
allez voir on va en tirer des bénéfices
incroyables
bon voila moi j'ai failli faire la vie
sur le bord d'une route par quelqu'un
qui roulait pas 80 km à 50 60 qui m'a
percuté la fracturer la rate et puis
voilà et les le personnel hospitalier a
été surchargé on en parle encore
aujourd'hui ils s'en sont pas rendu
compte et je mourrai dans un coin
tranquillement donc honnêtement voilà il
ya plein de façons mourir je moi
j'aimerais qu'on dise oui effectivement
on va tout régler effectivement mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait si si jamais c'est
pas suffisant des 170 puis à 60 puis à
50 ans on s'arrête ou mais voilà je
comprends pas donc globalement j'ai
l'impression qu'on a d'autres sujets sur
la table que celui là mais très bien on
part nous sommes juste en demandant
l'arrêt de chance elle est double
d'abord parce que je pense que il ya un
moment où il faut parier sur la
responsabilisation des gens même si
c'est vrai
les victimes sont très nombreuses parce
que sinon pourquoi ne pas s'arrêter à
quatre
pourquoi s'arrêter à 81 descendre 50 60
70 km et puis à une autre raison qui est
je pense qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
réfléchi au coût pour l'économie
française et mon avis n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt mais écouter celui de daniel
cohen c'est un économiste bien connu et
il était hier sur france culture dans
l'excellente émission l'esprit public
dire qu'on va réduire la vitesse
de 12% pour quelqu'un qui fait une heure
de trajet ça veut dire exactement 7 5
minutes perdues par jour ça fait quelque
chose entre 1 et 2 jours par an si tous
les français perdaient entre 1 et 2
jours par an en pourcentage du bib ça
ferait 0,3 pour cent du pime ça ferait 7
milliards pour 300 vies
combien vaut une vie moins festif à son
intéressant d'aborder sujet s'étaient
recueillies évidemment il ya la volonté
que tout le monde partage d'avoir moins
d'accidents mais il ya aussi le coup la
contrainte pour l'ensemble de l'économie
moi je prends pas du tout ça c'est un
argument d'économistes qui ce sont des
constructions intellectuelles totalement
abstraite
je suis plutôt que moins de 80 km heure
tout en mesurant parfaitement
effectivement ce que ça veut dire dans
la vie quotidienne
mais je prends deux raisons 1 c'est ce
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la
réussite d'une politique publique
en 1972 il ya seize mille tués sur les
routes de france
seize mille tués l'objectif est d'être à
à moins de 3000 et je me souviens dans
les années 90 on était à 8 mille tués
par an et on disait on peut pas passer
en dessous et dès lors que l'état est
devenu répressive c'était la seule
manière de faire on est passé sous les
4000 et ensuite on a effectivement
tangente et les 3000 et tous les pays
européens à l'exception de la grande
bretagne y avait tout à fait une autre
culture
tous les pays européens qui sont entrés
dans cette logique de répression à
travers des radars des amendes etc ont
vu leur mortalité et du coup le nombre
de blessés réduire réduire de façon
considérable considérable ensuite le
deuxième élément pour lequel je suis
très favorable il suffit de se promener
un tout petit peu en france est de voir
la manière dont on conduit dans les
départements ruraux et vous savez bien
que dès qu'on arrive dans un département
ont dit ah oui les savoyards sont ceux
qui conduisent le plus mal et puis quand
on est en gironde ce sont les girondins
forcément les gens qui connaissent le
terrain vont très vite parce qu'ils
connaissent leur route et on sait aussi
que les accidents mortels sont en
général à 15 km du domicile à 15 km du
domicile
donc il ya l'idée de il faut
effectivement responsabiliser les gens
mais quand
prenez n'importe quel journal heures pas
le figaro mais les journaux de province
sud ouest où la dépêche
lisez les faits divers ce ne sont que
des accidents liés à la consommation
d'alcool à des excès de vitesse
donc je pense effectivement que il n'y a
pas d'autre manière pas parce que nous
sommes aussi un peuple un peu un peu
réticent et qu'on a besoin d'être un
petit peu contrôlées pour essayer
d'avoir moins de tués sur les routes que
d'être finalement assez assez directif
alors comme il ya un consensus sur le
plateau je vais vous donner le point de
vue des internautes qui sont pas
forcément tous d'accord avec vous jeanne
qui nous dit pour les gens qui bossent
dans certaines régions où il n'y a que
des petites routes ça risque de poser
problème
robert naudi n'est ce pas là une
décision purement parisienne est
éloignée de la réalité du terrain
quant à christophe il nous dit
personnellement je ne comprends pas
cette polémique
surtout si c'est pour réduire les morts
sur les routes qu'est-ce que 10 km heure
en moins si l'on veut sauver des vies
donc le débat fait rage tandis que l'eau
nous dit si les français respecter le
code de la route on n'aurait pas eu
besoin de réduire la vitesse
bertrand du marais moi j'avais de
réaction de la première c'est j'ai le
plus grand respect pour daniel cohen
mais ils oublient que la plupart des
déplacements la très grande majorité des
déplacements encore une fois se fait au
sein des villes et des zones urbaines à
moins de 50 km donc en fait le calcul la
règle de trois elle est fausse parce que
et malheureusement pour les zones
rurales parce que il ya une ariane
appauvrissement une désindustrialisation
des zones rurales les échanges
économiques les échanges sociaux ils se
font plutôt en sein des villes et entre
les villes le deuxième point je voudrais
soulever c'est que on parle pas non plus
des zones dangereuses
en réalité quand on circule
tout tout tout les gens le savent que ce
soit en ville ou en sur les routes de
campagne
il ya des zones qui sont toujours
dangereuses à la nationale 10 9 et c est
ça moi je trouve qu'il y aurait une
politique comme en suède de l'examen
systématique de chaque accident pour
identifier
dans quelle mesure telle ou telle zone
est en creuse oui d'ailleurs certains
étaient favorables à ce que on limite la
circulation uniquement sur c'est sur ces
zones là alors comment on a beaucoup
beaucoup dans l'équipe de point de vue
pour ce que ce sujet intéresse notamment
celui d'une tentative de chiffrage du
coût économique de cette mesure
à côté de l'intervention de daniel cohen
il ya une chronique de pierre-yves
geoffard qui est un économiste était
dans libération c'était au mois d'avril
dernier il arrive à des chiffres qui
sont pas exactement ceux là mais enfin
il essaye aussi de calculer
de quoi il retourne et c'est extrêmement
intéressant
encore un mot sur ce sujet ça fait le
coup de dudu de la baisse du nombre de
blessés pour la sécurité sociale
alors ça effectivement c'est dans le
sait dans le calcul de derechazos
chiffre absolument considérable parce
que quelqu'un une question est ce que
quelqu'un a déjà fait puisque les faits
il n'y a pas de si longtemps que ça un
stage pour récupérer des points
non non c'est toujours au point où il a
plu des bons conducteurs bon j'étais à
deux on a douze 12 mois j'étais à 2 les
deux tiers des personnes présentes et
était là parce que vous avez les points
retirés à cause du téléphone portable
les deux tiers oui je crois que c'est
pas forcément l'édition de vitesse qui
est la leur pastis et les frustrations
et les feux rouges sont là aussi pour
une bonne part est bon de rire
donc globalement j'ai quand même
l'impression que les causes de mortalité
sont davantage dans le comportement du
conducteur
sachant que ce qui de toute façon ne
respectent pas la vitesse à 90 la
respecterons encore bien moins 80 g
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il
faut taper sur le conducteur l'a
parcouru pilot d'accord c'est à dire que
la répression effectivement des
fonctionne plus vous taper fort et plus
les personnes se disent bon l'important
champ je suis d'accord mais ça c'est
clair
alors pour être complètement au point
sur ce sujet vous pourrez avec profit à
les écouter le le décryptage fait par
philippe doucet qui est journaliste au
figaro et spécialistes de ces sujets
c'est sur figaro live donc si vous êtes
sur notre notre site internet en train
de regarder ça doit pas être très loin
et ça complètement rassuré tant qu'ils
peuvent les auditeurs je suis venu en
voiture pour cette émission là parce que
dans paris comme les transports en
commun sont pas climatisées
si on veut arriver à peu près
présentable on prend la voiture
individuelle et j'en profite pour dire
du mal de la mairie de paris et du stif
le stif c'est le syndicat inter des
petits avantages les transports publics
on va traverser la frontière si vous
voulez bien pour se rendre chez nos amis
allemands ont apparemment de morale en
allemagne en ce moment regardez cette
une du spiegel de ce week end le grand
journal de nos amis d'outre-rhin alors
je vous l'a traduit pour pour gagner du
temps
football politique économique il était
une